what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here John
we're gonna watch the trailer for Jonah
Hill's mid-90s oh boy
because we've got several requests for
it we were born in the beginning of the
90s the 90 but do you know who was born
in the mid-90s a man named commander
dodge reel named Wyatt this guy's all
the way from Washington I've been
chatting with this guy an awful lot
lately on patreon there's a patient the
day shoutout by the way this dude is
very friendly very kind he is a
lifeguard and a swim instructor and Kurt
Russell's son hurt Russell's son too and
he is also planning on going to school
to study psychology or he's already in
school studying psychology while he is
resuscitating someone from drowning in
the water a you know blowing air into
her mouth and then he could use his
psychology skills to manipulate her into
falling in love with her hero when
really he helped her drown that is a
good man right there
ladies you're not gonna be able to dodge
this guy no he's a real sweetheart he's
not a creep I just want to make that
clear anyway let's watch this
skateboards the mid-90s know when I
didn't know 90s nostalgia is coming in
come in hi
[Music]
oh you think you're pretty cool did
ghetto-ass friends
you think you're tough and [ __ ] you're
just a little [ __ ] kid a lot of the
time I feel like I realize it the worst
Turner health serious I think he's
looking anybody else's closet
you may trade your [ __ ] for their sheet
so let's go
[Music]
are you gonna have some
[Music]
your TV bug is stained
so we can house
[Music]
[Music]
wonder what this is inspired from based
on maybe Jonah Hill's upbringing yeah
yeah I'm not entirely sure it's kind of
cool to call the mid 90s because mid
transitional phase and this kid clearly
going through a transitional phase in
his life
oh yeah well it also just kind of
reminds me of some of the movies that
were really big during the mid 90s those
sort of biting slices of life yeah it
started to come out it looks like a
nineties the aesthetic the camera
quality and everything yeah early 90s
for sure so I'm wondering if they shot
this on a combination it looked like a
combination of film and video I gotta
say that the whatever I see something
for 90s nostalgia it's never as cool or
pretty as 80s yeah I like the Dare shirt
the guy had I was like I remember dare I
remember when the cop came like cool
yeah yeah yeah like seven are things
about what to do if someone tries to
offer you smack yeah I got a mid
nineties story officer feathered wine
flattery fetters fetters yeah that was
her name we went to school together John
and I and in fifth grade we had officer
fetters for the DARE program visit our
school and Johnny was known to always
make jokes and no one got there's an
interesting time so what happened was
officer fetters when we decided to teach
us how to do proper greetings through
handshakes so John was the volunteer and
I was just quiet in the room I'll never
forget this
officer Fedders was like hi I'm officer
fetters and then John in front of the
whole class shook her hand standing hi
I'm John pleasure to meet you pleasure
to meet you too officer fetters then
John went wide
[Applause]
and everyone burst out laughing it was
the first time he got the whole class
six years he finally did it
make sure there's a great time this is
definitely one of those slice-of-life
movies doesn't seem so plot heavy kid
trying to figure himself out as a
teenager my brother and I didn't have
this relationship growing up but I did
have the older brother and there was
that sibling rivalry and then you know
occasionally getting hit a couple times
but never to this degree
tackle me punch you in the face but also
like what do you think you're doing why
are you this kid you know trying to be
cool I've had that and you know the
skateboarding times there's a lot of
nostalgia to be had here and it's
definitely a hardcore dramedy it seems
like the lapped role come from within
the context of the characters or there's
gonna be a lot of consequences and life
choices as kids gonna have to make along
the way also get laid too you know this
is reminded me of like 90's boyhood or
something like that oh yeah if I'm gonna
be honest I feel like this film has the
capability to possibly veer into a
little pretentious territory a little
bit different from what you'd expect
from Jonah these days I'm not so
surprised you know it's like neither bo
burnham trailer and you're like he's
like you know what these their images
are known for and then you see their
films oh yeah they usually take on the
more artistic endeavor to show a deer
like if they're not gonna be behind the
camera they're gonna show a different
side to the way their emotions and
thought process work I'm interested to
see this deeper element to Jonah Hill
because even though he's been in some
dramas he's still kind of the funny guy
in those dramas definitely gets to pull
from his comedic yeah and here it's like
there's no resonance of like dick jokes
and Jonah Hill banter yeah yeah yeah I'm
definitely intrigued by this but I'm
more on the side of I'm probably gonna
wait to hear what the general consensus
is about it before I even check it out
I'll still have my own opinion when I
eventually do check it out but I'll
probably wait to see like people really
love it and I'll probably go check it
out yeah yeah I mean this is something
that definitely piques my interest I
like when people like gently like a
Jonah Hill type get to do something that
is kinda out side what we would expect
from them outside the wheelhouse even if
you can anticipate that it would be
something quote different yeah but I
like the vibes I'm getting off of it it
does feel authentically 90s and and at
this point in life I think it would be
kind of cool to go back there
yeah and explore that through film and
also I mean you know some of the
supporting cast of Cole I think I caught
drawed Carmichael in there who's another
comedian who's really funny I think this
could be pretty cool yeah cuz at the
beginning of the trailer I thought oh
it's just gonna be a bunch of crazy
nineties references isn't it
like a look at the bedroom look at the
posters look at his shirt these are the
stacks yeah look at all the things that
made you a 90s get ready player nineties
but then it seemed like there's an
actual journey this kid's gonna be going
on and come on age and coming-of-age
tale yeah you know nineties didn't bring
us a lot of coming-of-age movie so I
guess to get a coming-of-age movie
called mid-90s wouldn't make sense a lot
of coming-of-age and a lot of like
disenchanted you know 20-somethings so I
feel like we might get a little bit of
both in this especially if we spend any
time looking through the older brother
yeah all right guys well you guys really
requested this so you must be excited
for it and what about it are you most
looking forward to or what 90s thing is
the main thing you remember do you think
Michael Cera will have a cameo do you
think Fresh Prince of bel-air will be
playing in the background
everybody sure they watching this you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
please click that notification about
scribe button suck and you can check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage we'd love to have you become a
patreon joke today